[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by edie patterson
aka judy gemstone from the righteous
gemstones which comes out this sunday on
hbo hbo max how you doing today edie
doing great how are you doing steve
i'm doing good i got you know even just
going into this interview misbehaving is
still in my head um
i need to know what the prep was like
for you yeah right what was the prep
like doing misbehaving was that intense
to perform it or to write it
both
well hang on i'm having bangs trouble
here we go do your thing wow
um
the writing of it was
hilariously fast like
shockingly fast so we knew this was
going to be a thing and we it was in a
few scripts and we were like okay
amy lee and baby billy's
famous hit is called misbehaving we
didn't know what this song was or what
it was about we just had decided that
was the name of it
and then one day danny was like i think
it's sort of like um
mama told me not to i did it anyway msp
and i was like
oh dude i understand now i know i know
what you're doing
and so um
then i wrote a verse and maybe like a
bridge and
wrote some stuff about we thought we was
just messing around until we met that
man in a thorny crown i wrote the weird
thing about putting on lipstick and
shaving
um
all that and so we had about like maybe
a verse and a half and a chorus maybe a
little bridge and i just sang it into
danny's phone we weirdly kind of knew
what the melody would be
and then we sent it to joey stevens
who's the composer on the show and he
heard it was like oh right and wrote
like two verses and added music and
yeah we had a version of it the next day
and then never changed it because it
just seemed to like
come into the world right
yeah
it's perfect and there's something just
that sucks in your brain like it won't
leave your brain like i i've watched the
show a while ago and first came out
still with me um which is amazing um
so also one of my favorite my favorite
scene of you in season one was the scene
where
judy is pushing the shopping cart into
the car
what went into filming that day like
what exactly is happening during that
well
so
what lot going on that day um
we
well first of all i didn't know that um
that type of car is basically made this
is a side note but that type of car is
basically made of a really hard plastic
and i had in my head i was like oh this
is going to feel so satisfying to just
crunch this car and i really thought a
shopping cart would like
sort of go in and embed and make a dent
i don't know i had this cartoon idea of
like what it meant to smash up a car
and uh basically a shopping cart just
bounces off of a car like that and so
you have to come at it sideways to try
to do damage and so it's all these
things and figuring out like how do we
make a mark on this thing
yeah i i love that and yeah it's just
hysterical watching and that's all about
the character of judy and how you betray
her is that like i never know what's
going to happen any scene she's in and i
love the little lines you throw in and i
want to ask you
lines that are like my favorite line she
actually says it's random but in season
one when she's in her dad's office she
slams the door and says good night in
broad daylight little things like that
make me like laugh my ass off so i'm
wondering though are lines like that
free yeah are those mostly improvised by
you or is that are you kind of putting
on the script before
there is a fair amount of improv but
that was for sure written i remember
writing okay i just remember thinking
like
um
that it'd be fun if she's so flustered
she says goodnight and then
kelvin tries to kelvin tries to own her
for saying that
yeah no that that was great and speaking
of that with the sibling dynamic in the
show how much comfort do you have to
have as an actress with danny and adam
to sell this sibling relationship in a
show like this
oh dude i think the comfort
level has to be off the charts and i
can't
believe
how lucky we were to just like have that
from the jump
um
yeah i
it's
yeah it's magic i don't yeah i don't
even understand how it happened but i
feel
absolutely comfortable
with both of them and yeah and i think
they do with me too we're very like
uh
comfortable in every way physically and
um
feel like we can say anything to each
other and um it's really really fun
yeah and it shows on screen and speaking
of like magic relationships really also
is bj and judy
so what what exactly is it about bj that
judy like can't get enough of why why
does she go for bj
i think she goes for bj because he is
sweet i think she is fascinated by
the fact that he is um
sweet and sees her i don't think there's
a ton of people in her life who um
understand that when she
acts like a wild animal that she
isn't necessarily coming
for them
like i think bj knows like
to not always get his feelings hurt by
her and i think that's not that's not um
a normal human trait that people would
know that with judy
i love that um so the traits of judy too
and she has this complicated character
um is there anything you can find in her
that you can relate to that you kind of
see yourself in oh yeah i mean i i
i love judy i think she is doing her
damn best
and is trying really
trying really hard um she just happens
to you know
have
there's no there's no thing inside that
goes like okay take a deep breath think
this through
yeah
she's just always set to pop and i um
yeah i i i think everything about judy
is inside of me but i just try to turn
it up for her and let it run right
things that i would maybe things that i
would maybe have enough um
uh
human decency or uh
even
even ego or consideration to go okay
slow it down you may be feeling this
right now slow it down for a second try
to hear their side of it i think the fun
thing about judy is it's all just human
stuff but there's no
there's no voice of reason it's just
like sure it's going to come out
yeah 100 and i have to ask too and i
think people watching us are going to
think is i was expecting to see like the
luscious curls here so your hair looks
great nice and straight thanks but what
what goes into like was that always
going to be she's going to have curly
hair like when you're making this
character is that such an important
character choice
you know it that was a really important
character choice to me i just really
uh i talked to danny really early on
about it and i was like i just i feel
like her hair is so curly and i feel
like it's um
i feel like because really curly hair
and especially like that length of curly
hair moves in a different way and
there's um
depending on the person who's wearing
the hair
there can be like just a hint of um
if there's a hint of awkwardness in the
person the hair does like an extra thing
and adds to it and i just really and i
just
the way she felt in my body felt just
like a little bit awkward and off and i
was like i think i just need that hair
to enhance that feeling i'm having and i
really it really makes me happy the
second my hair
is
like that i feel like i instantly am her
i get i understand her immediately when
my hair is like that
oh that that's amazing that's just
awesome to hear and
it's awesome just talking to you and
everybody be excited
righteous gemstones is back this sunday
the first two episodes will be on hbo
nhl max you can watch easy patterson
crush it as judy purr usual edie thank
you so much for joining me today i hope
to see you again in the future
oh thanks steve that was really fun